de mi sola es una deportista nigeriana
de 28 años que a los 11 meses de nacida
contrajo poliomielitis una enfermedad
viral que produce debilidad muscular y
parálisis en cuestión de horas esto no
le impidió desarrollarse físicamente y
practicar actividades para volver más
fuerte su cuerpo sin embargo su infancia
se vio empañada por el dolor emocional
de usar prendas demasiado grandes para
ocultar su dificultad para caminar
empecé a usar ropa grande porque pensé
que podía cubrir mi forma de caminar
pero obviamente no podía
'yo a ropa muy grande también trata de
hacer un poco más masculina y de ocultar
todas mis emociones para que lo que
dijeran no me afectara
desde hace cuatro años el continente
africano no registra un solo caso de
polio la organización mundial de la
salud celebró la noticia y declaró
oficialmente erradicada la enfermedad
del continente
es uno de los mayores honores de mi vida
unirme a ustedes en la celebración de la
erradicación del poliovirus salvaje en
los 47 estados miembros de la región
africana de la umh
este es el segundo virus que se elimina
a nuestro continente después de la
erradicación de la viruela hace 40 años
la solución más eficaz es la vacunación
temprana ya que los menores de 5 años
son los más vulnerables